>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
YOU'VE GOT TO HANDED TO THE THE
BIDEN PEOPLE.
THEY DON'T SPECIALIZE IN
SUBTLETY, YOU'RE NOT GOING TO
MISS THE POINT WHEN THEY TALK.
AND THEY'VE BEEN TALKING A LOT
ABOUT FOREIGN POLICY FOR MONTHS,
THE WHITE HOUSE HAS TOLD US THAT
IF WE ARE REAL AMERICANS, IF WE
LOVE THIS COUNTRY AND AREN'T
TRADERS, QUISLINGS, AND WE WILL
WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT JUMPING
WITH BOTH FEET INTO A HIGHLY
COMPLICATED CONFLICT IN AN
OBSCURE PART OF EASTERN EUROPE
WHERE WE HAVE NO NATIONAL
INTERESTS.
WHY?
BECAUSE UKRAINE'S BORDERS ARE
SACRED, UNLIKE YOUR OWN, AND IF
WE ARE GOOD PEOPLE, WE WILL
RECOGNIZE THAT AND NOT ASK ANY
QUESTIONS.
SO THAT'S BEEN THEIR ARGUMENT.
YOU MAY NOTICE IT'S NOT ACTUALLY
AN ARGUMENT.
IT DOESN'T EVEN APPROACH AND
ARGUMENT.
IT IS A LECTURE.
IT IS DELIVERED AT HIGH-VOLUME
WITH THEIR SIGNATURE FRESHMAN
YEAR SELF-RIGHTEOUSNESS.
HOW DARE YOU!
NO ONE FROM THE BIDEN
WHITE HOUSE IS ACTUALLY TRYING
TO CONVINCE YOU OF ANYTHING.
THEY LEAVE THAT FOR PEOPLE THEY
CARE ABOUT, LIKE THEIR DONORS.
THEY ARE NOT TELLING YOU THAT
WHAT HAPPENS IN UKRAINE IS MORE
IMPORTANT THAN WHAT HAPPENS IN
YOUR COUNTRY, ALTHOUGH OBVIOUSLY
THAT'S THE UNDERLYING
ASSUMPTION, THEY CERTAINLY
BELIEVE THAT, BUT THEY CAN'T SAY
IT OUT LOUD.
THEY RARELY SAY ANYTHING THEY
MEAN OUT LOUD.
WHAT THEY DO, AND WHAT THEY'RE
DOING NOW IS THEY JUST YELL AT
YOU ABOUT EVERYTHING.
SHUT UP, PROLE!
TAKE THE SHOT!
SURRENDER THAT CIVIL LIBERTY.
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO UKRAINE OR
ELSE YOU ARE A DANGEROUS TOOL OF
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
IT'S A HEAVY HAND.
THIS, ONCE AGAIN, IS NOT SUBTLE
STUFF, NOT A LIGHT TOUCH, SO WHY
DID THEY DO IT?
WELL, THEY DO IT BECAUSE IT
WORKS.
YOU CAN SEE IT ON DISPLAY IN
WASHINGTON EVEN IN THAT
SUPPOSEDLY DIVIDED CITY, A PLACE
WHERE YOU HEAR ABOUT
PARTISANSHIP, A PLACE WHERE
NOTHING GETS DONE.
WELL, SOME THINGS GET DONE.
YOU'LL NOTE THAT NOT A SINGLE
REPUBLICAN LEADER HAS STOOD UP
TO POINT OUT HOW INSANE ALL OF
THIS IS AND HOW COMPLETELY
DIVORCED IT IS FROM ANYTHING
THAT AMERICAN VOTERS ACTUALLY
CARE ABOUT.
JUST THE OPPOSITE.
IF YOU LISTEN TO
MITCH McCONNELL, THE LEADER OF
REPUBLICANS IN THE SENATE, YOU
WOULD THINK THAT WITH THE
AVERAGE WELDER BACK IN HIS HOME
STATE OF KENTUCKY REALLY WANTS
MORE THAN A PAY RAISE OR AN
AFFORDABLE VACATION OR DECENT
SCHOOLS FOR HIS CHILDREN, WHAT
HE REALLY WANTS IS AN END TO
RUSSIAN AGGRESSION AGAINST THE
BRAVE PEOPLE OF EASTERN UKRAINE.
AND THAT'S WIFE YOU GO TO ANY
DOLLAR STORE IN THE STATE FROM
ASHLAND TO COVINGTON, YOU'LL
FIND WHAT THEY USED TO CALL
REGULAR FOLKS MUTTERING BITTERLY
ABOUT THAT VLADIMIR PUTIN.
WILL HE CROSSED THE RIVER ON THE
WAY?
HOW CAN ZELENSKY STOP HIM?
AT ARE THE MOLDOVAN SAFE?
WHAT ABOUT HOLDOVERS TERRITORIAL
INTEGRITY?
THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE TALKING
ABOUT IN KENTUCKY TONIGHT.
OF COURSE IT'S POSSIBLE -- WE
HAVEN'T RUN A POLL OR ANYTHING,
THAT SOME IN KENTUCKY AND IN
FACT ABOUT 49 OTHER STATES MIGHT
BE WONDERING TONIGHT ABOUT GAS
PRICES, AND THEY HAVE REASON TO
WONDER.
THE PRICE OF ENERGY IS ABOUT TO
GO UP DRAMATICALLY IN THIS
COUNTRY THANKS TO JOE BIDEN'S
ADVENTURISM EASTERN EUROPE.
SO THAT'S A NEWS STORY TOO AND
OUR OWN PETER DOOCY ASKED ABOUT
HER TODAY IN THE WHITE HOUSE
BRIEFING.
WATCH.
>> GAS IN CALIFORNIA IS ALMOST
$5 A GALLON.
SHOULD PEOPLE ACROSS THE COUNTRY
EXPECT TO SEE THAT KIND OF A
NUMBER WHEN THEY GO TO GAS UP
THEIR CAR, $5, $6?
>> Secretary Psaki: I THINK AS
YOU ARE THE PRESIDENT SAY LAST
WEEK, STANDING UP FOR OUR VALUES
IS NOT WITHOUT COST.
>> Tucker: OH.
THAT'S THE "ANSWER."
STANDING UP FOR OUR VALUES IS
NOT WITHOUT COSTS, SCHOOLS THE
GENDER STUDIES MAJOR FROM
OBERLIN COLLEGE.
FAIR ENOUGH.
BUT THAT RAISES TWO QUESTIONS.
WHAT EXACTLY ARE OUR VALUES AND
WHAT IS THE COST?
WE CAN'T ANSWER THE FIRST
QUESTION WITH ANY DECISION, THE
WE ARE PRETTY CERTAIN IT IS
SOMETHING TO DO WITH TRANS
RIGHTS.
HOW COULD IT NOT, THOSE ARE
VALUES.
AS FOR THE COST?
WHAT IS THE COST?
WELL, HERE'S NBC NEWS.
>> THE NATIONAL AVERAGE NOW THE
HIGHEST SINCE 2014 AT 3.51 A
GALLON.
UP $0.20 IN A MONTH, UP $0.88
FROM YEAR AGO.
CALIFORNIA WITH ITS HIGHER GAS
TAX IS NOW AVERAGING $4.72 A
GALLON, $4.82 IN THE BAY AREA.
RUSSIA IS THE THIRD LARGEST OIL
PRODUCER.
EXPERTS WARNED THAT AN INVASION,
SANCTIONS, AND COUNTER SANCTIONS
WOULD PUSH GAS PRICES TO AN
ALL-TIME HIGH.
>> I THINK THAT COMBINED WITH
THE SEASONAL INGREDIENTS WOULD
PUSH THE NATIONAL AVERAGE UP
BEYOND THE $4-GALLON MARK.
JUST A MATTER OF TIME.
>> POTENTIALLY PUSHING $6 A
GALLON IN CALIFORNIA.
>> Tucker: $6 A GALLON.
OIL TONIGHT BROACHING $100 A
BARREL.
THE LONGEST IT'S BEEN THAT HIGH
IN A LONG TIME.
SO THAT'S NOT A SMALL THING, AND
IT DOESN'T JUST APPLY TO YOU IF
YOU DRIVE A CAR.
IF YOU PURCHASE ANY PHYSICAL
OBJECT IT'S ALMOST CERTAIN THAT
OBJECT HAD TO BE DRIVEN TO YOU
BY SOMEONE WHO BURNS GASOLINE,
SO THE PRICE OF EVERYTHING IS
ABOUT TO RISE.
AND IN A COUNTRY THAT JUST
BENEATH THE SURFACE IS A LOT
POORER THAN IT LOOKS, THAT'S NOT
A SMALL THING.
IN FACT, IT'S GOING TO BE A
TRAGEDY FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE,
ILLEGITIMATE TRAGEDY, SO IF YOU
CARED ABOUT THE PEOPLE YOU
GOVERNED, THAT WOULD NOT BE
SOMETHING YOU BLOW OFF WITH A
FLIP OF THE HAND AS THE COST OF
OUR VALUES.
YOU'D CARE.
WHAT YOU CERTAINLY WOULDN'T DO
IF YOU WANTED TO PRESERVE
DOMESTIC STABILITY IS MAKE IT
VERY, VERY OBVIOUS THAT YOU
DON'T CARE AT ALL.
AND YET THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT
THEY'RE DOING.
THEY ARE TELLING YOU TO YOUR
FACE WE DON'T CARE.
WATCH THIS GUY ON CNN.
>> WILL THERE BE ADDITIONAL
ECONOMIC PRESSURE ON AMERICANS
AND PEOPLE AROUND THE WORLD IF
WE STAND UP TO AGGRESSION?
YES.
BUT WHAT THE SACRIFICE THAT'S
BEING REQUESTED FROM PEOPLE
POTENTIALLY TO DEFEND DEMOCRACY
IN THE LIBERAL INTERNATIONAL
ORDER THAT HAS BROUGHT IN 75
YEARS OF PEACE AND PROSPERITY IN
EUROPE, SOMETHING UNPRECEDENTED
IN THE WAKE OF WORLD WAR II THAT
AMERICA AND ITS ALLIES HELPED
BUILD.
WE NEED TO A MEMBER THAT WE ARE
NOT FRAGILE.
WE ARE NOT, AS CHURCHILL SAID,
MADE OF SUGAR CANDY.
DEALING WITH A LITTLE BIT OF
DIFFICULTY TO STAND ON
AUTHORITARIANISM AND AUTOCRACY
IS NOT TOO MUCH TO ASK.
WE NEED TO STRAIGHTEN AND
STIFFEN OUR SPINES A LITTLE BIT.
>> Tucker: HE QUOTED
CHURCHILL, HE MUST BE ONTO
SOMETHING.
HE'S CHANNELING ONE OF THE GREAT
LEADERS OF THE ANGLOSPHERE,
WINSTON CHURCHILL.
A COUPLE QUESTIONS.
HOW ARE WE DEFINING LIBERAL
DEMOCRACY?
HOW ARE WE DEFINING
INTERNATIONAL ORDER?
HOW ARE WE DEFINING SACRIFICE?
NONE OF THOSE TERMS ARE EVER
DEFINED, BUT IT'S THE LAST ONE
THAT THEY SPEND THE LEAST AMOUNT
OF TIME ON.
SACRIFICE.
BECAUSE OF COURSE THE SACRIFICE
WILL BE YOURS.
IT WILL NOT BE THEIRS.
THE PERSON YOU JUST SAW SPEAKING
LIVES IN A DUPLEX IN
NEW YORK CITY THAT WAS ONCE
OWNED BY THE ASTOR FAMILY.
WE KNOW THAT BECAUSE HE INVITED
A "NEW YORK TIMES" REPORTER AND
PHOTOGRAPHER INTO ITS OWN TO
BRAG ABOUT HOW RICH HE IS.
THERE'S NOTHING WRONG WITH BEING
RICH, BUT IF YOU ARE IT'S
PROBABLY UNWISE TO GIVE THE BACK
OF THE HAND TO PEOPLE WHO AREN'T
MEANT TO TELL HIM YES, YOU'RE
GETTING A LOT POORER, BUT THAT'S
OKAY BECAUSE IT WILL MAKE ME
FEEL BETTER ABOUT MYSELF.
THAT POSTURE, OVER TIME, IS MORE
CORROSIVE OF SOCIAL COHESION --
INFECTIVE DEMOCRACY -- THAT MAY
BE ANY OTHER AND HISTORY IS
LITTERED WITH FALLEN REGIMES
THAT HAVE PROVED THAT.
LET THEM EAT CAKE.
SO EVEN AT CNN, WHO SHOWS ARE
NOT ANCHORED BY GENIUSES, AND
EVEN ON THE SHOW, WHICH IS
ANCHORED BY THE FORMER MORNING
ZOO HOST FROM TACOMA -- SO SHE
SAID SO.
>> THAT'S A LOT TO ASK.
GETTING PEOPLE TO FOCUS ON
DEMOCRACY WHEN THE BIG TABLE
ISSUES ARE EATING THEM UP.
>> I THINK TWO THINGS ABOUT
THAT.
BUT YOU'RE RIGHT, OBVIOUSLY
PEOPLE ARE FEELING A LOT OF
DIFFICULTY BUT THAT'S ALSO WHERE
GOVERNMENT CAN TAKE ACTION TO
ALLEVIATE SOME SHORT-TERM STRESS
AND I KNOW FOLKS ARE TIRED.
I KNOW THEY ARE FRUSTRATED BUT
WHAT WE ARE BEING ASKED TO DO,
WHAT WE'VE BEEN ASKED TO DO IS
FAR LESS THAN OTHER GENERATIONS
HAVE BEEN ASKED TO DO.
>> Tucker: WE ARE BEING ASKED
TO DO -- BEING ASKED TO.
-- SHE WILL BE ABLE TO GO ON
VACATION WITH YOUR FAMILY THE
SUMMER, SURE.
THE STAPLES THAT YOU USE EVERY
SINGLE DAY MAYBE OUT OF REACH
BUT IT'S NOT A BIG DEAL BECAUSE
DUNKIRK.
IMAGINE.
BUT IT'S NOT JUST THAT GUY, THAT
DIM BULB LECTURING US ABOUT HOW
THE SACRIFICE IS WORTH IT.
IT'S VIRTUALLY EVERYONE IN
POWER.
WHAT BASIS IS IT WORTH IT?
THEY'LL HAVE THE SAME LINE.
IT'S NOT REHEARSED OR ANYTHING.
THEY'RE TELLING US THAT BEING
ABLE TO DEFEND DEMOCRACY, OUR
GREAT PRIVILEGE, WILL MAKE ALL
THE SUFFERING WORTH IT.
WATCH.
>> THE REALITY IS THAT THIS IS A
MOMENT WHERE WE WILL HAVE TO
EXPERIENCE SOME SHORT-TERM PAIN
IN ORDER TO MAKE VERY CLEAR THAT
PUTIN CANNOT INVADE UKRAINE.
>> YES, THERE'S LIKELY TO BE A
COST.
EXACTLY WHAT THE COST IS GOING
TO BE WILL BE IN THE POCKETS OF
THE AMERICANS.
THERE'S NO DOUBT ABOUT THAT.
>> MY .2 PEOPLE HERE AT HOME IS
YOU CAN EXPECT GAS PRICES TO GO
UP, YOU CAN EXPECT FOOD COSTS TO
GO UP, AND I CAN TELL YOU FROM
HISTORY, ANYTIME WE WATCH THE
RIGHT OF ONE GROUP THE
EVISCERATED, IT'S JUST A MATTER
OF TIME BEFORE IT COMES BACK TO
HAUNT US.
>> Tucker: IT'S A LITTLE
GALLING TO BE LECTURED BY PEOPLE
WITH IMPOSSIBLY GENERATION
CONGRESSIONAL PENSIONS ABOUT
SACRIFICES YOU GET TO MAKE.
BUT IT'S ESPECIALLY INFURIATING
TO HAVE THE LAST GUY SPEAKING OF
FOOD RACES, HAS SKIPPED VERY FEW
MEALS RECENTLY, TELL YOU THAT
LOOKING AT HISTORY INFORMS YOU
OF EVERYTHING YOU NEED TO KNOW
ABOUT THE FUTURE.
IT REALLY?
WHAT SORT OF HISTORY ARE WE
TALKING ABOUT?
HOW ABOUT LAST YEAR, WHEN THE
WITHDRAWAL FROM AFGHANISTAN
HUMILIATED, DEGRADED, AND
WEAKENS THIS COUNTRY.
LINDSEY GRAHAM SUPPORTIVELY
CARES ABOUT THE MILITARY, DID HE
DO A SINGLE THING TO IMPROVE IT?
DID HE CALL FOR THE RESIGNATION
OF ANY PERSON RESPONSIBLE FOR
THAT HUMILIATING DISASTER THAT
RESULTED IN THE DEATHS OF
AMERICAN CITIZENS?
NO, HE DIDN'T.
IN THOSE SAME PEOPLE ARE NOW IN
CHARGE OF OUR STRATEGY IN
UKRAINE.
SO YOU CAN CALL THAT HISTORY AND
IT MIGHT BE WORTH LEARNING FROM
IT.
ONE OF THE THINGS YOU LEARN AS
THE PEOPLE CURRENTLY IN CHARGE
HAVE AN EXTENSIVE AND EASILY
VERIFIABLE TRACK RECORD OF
FAILURE WHEN THEY INTERVENE INTO
THE HIGHLY COMPLEX AFFAIRS OF
OTHER COUNTRIES, COUNTRIES WHOSE
LANGUAGES THEY DON'T SPEAK AND
WHOSE HISTORIES THEY DON'T
UNDERSTAND.
PEOPLE WHO BY HUBRIS AND BOREDOM
WIND UP INTERJECTING THEMSELVES
INTO PLACES THEY KNOW NOTHING
ABOUT.
THE BIGGER QUESTION REALLY FOR
LINDSEY GRAHAM IS ONE IS THE
LAST TIME HE DID ANYTHING, ONE
THING, TO IMPROVE THE LIFE OF AN
AMERICAN CITIZEN OTHER THAN
HIMSELF?
GAS PRICES ARE UP, FOOD PRICES
ARE.
THAT'S OKAY, BECAUSE IT WON'T
AFFECT LINDSEY GRAHAM.
HE DOESN'T HAVE KIDS AND HE'S
GOT THAT GENERAL TO GENEROUS
CONGRESSIONAL PENSION.
WHAT ABOUT YOU?
YOU ARE GOING TO BE REPAID IN
VIRTUE.
NOW, IT'S NOT CASH.
IT'S NOT EVEN CRYPTOCURRENCY.
IT'S BETTER.
FOR THE REST OF YOUR LIFE YOU
CAN FEEL GOOD ABOUT HAVING
SUPPORTED SOMETHING CALLED
DEMOCRACY, SOMETHING THAT IS IN
SHORTER SUPPLY IN THIS COUNTRY
THAN IT'S EVER BEEN, BUT
SOMETHING THAT WE HOPE TO DEFEND
IN A COUNTRY YOU CAN'T IDENTIFY
ON A MAP.
SO YOU MAY BE POOR.
IT'S ALL MOST CERTAIN THAT YOU
WILL BE, BUT YOU CAN BE VERY
PROUD OF THAT.
AND BY THE WAY, IF YOU DON'T DO
THAT, YOU'RE A MURDERER.
HERE'S OUR DAILY REMINDER FROM
MR. ALEXANDER VEND BEEN, A ON
MSNBC.
>> WHEN YOU HAVE TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF CASUALTIES, THE
REPUBLICANS ARE GOING TO OWN IT.
TUCKER CARLSON IS GOING TO OWN
THIS.
HE'S BASICALLY DIGGING HIS OWN
GRAVE, SO TO SPEAK, HIS
POLITICAL GRAVE.
IT IS GOING TO BE A MEAT GRINDER
AND HE JUST WENT ON RECORD,
TUCKER CARLSON, DONALD TRUMP,
BASICALLY ENCOURAGING THIS.
I THINK THIS IS THE BEGINNING OF
THE END OF THESE, YOU KNOW,
COMPLETELY OUT OF TOUCH, FAR
RIGHT WHACK JOBS THAT ARE
BASICALLY ENCOURAGING PUTIN TO
TAKE THIS ACTION.
>> Tucker: SO IT TURNS OUT
IT'S NOT VLADIMIR PUTIN WHO'S
INVADING UKRAINE.
IT'S THE REPUBLICANS.
IF DONALD TRUMP AND THE FOX NEWS
TALK SHOWS, THEY ARE INVADING UG
OUT DEMOCRACY.
WHY DO WE PLAY THAT?
WHY DO WE GET THAT GUY AIRTIME?
BECAUSE IT'S JUST INTERESTING TO
CHECK IN ON THE HYSTERIA LEVELS.
JUST HOW FLORID ARE THEY?
HOW RED IN THE FACE AND PRAISED
ARE THEY?
THEY ARE AT 11 THIS WEEK.
ANY CRITICISM AT ALL, ANY
QUESTION AT ALL EVOKES THAT KIND
OF PERFORMANCE.
WHY IS IT IN AMERICA'S INTEREST
TO DO THIS?
THAT SEEMS LIKE A FAIR QUESTION.
SHUT UP, YOUR HITLER!
[CACKLES]
AND WE ARE NOT OVERSTATING IT!
BEFORE WE PLAY THIS NEXT CLIP,
FROM NANCY PELOSI, SPEAKER OF
THE HOUSE, IT TELLS YOU A LOT.
IF YOU RESPOND TO A QUESTION
LIKE "HOW DOES THIS HELP US" BY
ACCUSING THE PERSON WHO ASKED
THE QUESTION OF EVIL MOTIVES, OF
WORKING FOR SATAN, OR WORSE,
YOU'RE PROBABLY NOT COMING FROM
A POSITION OF STRENGTH.
STRONG PEOPLE ARE COMA.
THEY KNOW WHAT THEY THINK, THEY
KNOW WHY THEY ARE DOING WHAT
THEY'RE DOING.
THEY KNOW HOW TO CONVINCE YOU TO
SUPPORT THEM AND THAT.
PEOPLE WHO KNOW THEY ARE WRONG,
MORE DOING SOMETHING THAT THEY
DON'T WANT REVEALED IN PUBLIC,
BECOME HYSTERICAL, AND SO THESE
PEOPLE ARE HYSTERICAL.
AS PROMISED, HERE'S
NANCY PELOSI.
>> THIS IS A VERY EVIL MOVE ON
THE PART OF VLADIMIR PUTIN.
HE'S A KGB GUY WHO HAPPENS TO BE
PROBABLY THE RICHEST MAN IN THE
WORLD BECAUSE OF HIS
EXPLOITATION OF HIS OWN PEOPLE
THAT HE DOESN'T WANT THEM TO
KNOW ABOUT.
THIS, MY FRIENDS, IS OUR MOMENT.
THAT'S WHAT PEOPLE WERE SAYING
THERE.
>> Tucker: IT'S OUR MOMENT!
[CACKLES]
DID YOU CATCH THAT?
SO IT'S A NAZI THING.
LIKE EVERY THING ELSE THEY DON'T
LIKE.
ANYONE WHO OPPOSES ELECTION
FRAUD IS A NAZI.
GOT IT, THAT'S THE TEMPLATE,
ALWAYS.
BUT IT'S KIND OF WEIRD TEMPLATE,
NOT TO GET TOO LITERAL OR
ANYTHING, TO APPLY IN THIS
CIRCUMSTANCE SINCE TECHNICALLY
IT WAS RUSSIA THAT FOUGHT THEM
AND MORE THAN ANY OTHER COUNTRY
BEAT THEM.
JUST SAYING.
WHILE IT WAS UKRAINE THAT
COLLABORATED WITH THE NAZIS.
IF THAT DOESN'T MEAN THEY'RE
DOING IT NOW.
BUT AS LONG AS WE'RE PULLING OUT
THE HISTORICAL REFERENCES...
THAT'S TRUE.
YOU THINK NANCY PELOSI WOULD
KNOW THAT.
SHE WAS ACTUALLY ALIVE AT THE
TIME.
BELIEVE IT OR NOT NANCY PELOSI
WAS BORN BEFORE THE SECOND
WORLD WAR EVEN STARTED.
BUT WHATEVER, ALL BAD THINGS ARE
NAZI THINGS.
AND ALL GOOD THINGS ARE
DEMOCRACY THINGS.
WATCH.
>> I THINK THE ONE THING THAT WE
ALL AGREE UPON IS THE ATTACK ON
THE UKRAINE BY THE RUSSIANS IS
AN ATTACK ON DEMOCRACY.
>> PUTIN IS TERRIFIED BY THE
PROSPECT OF A DEMOCRACY AT HIS
BORDER.
>> AND THAT'S WHY DEFENDANT
DEMOCRACY BOTH AT HOME AND
ABROAD MUST BE AN URGENT
NATIONAL SECURITY PRIORITY.
>> WHAT IS OUR DEMOCRACY WORTH
IF WE ARE NOT ABLE AND WILLING
TO STAND AGAINST AN INVASION OF
ANOTHER DEMOCRACY?
>> Tucker: YOU'VE JUST GOT TO
PLAY THE CLIP OF THE LAST GUY
WITH HIS WEIRD SCRAGGLY BEARD.
ALWAYS LOOKS LIKE HE'S READING
SOMETHING.
CAN'T QUITE PRONOUNCE THE WORDS.
IT'S ABOUT DEMOCRACY.
WE TOLD YOU NIGHT AFTER NIGHT,
NOT BECAUSE WE ARE ANTI-UKRAINE
OR PRO-RUSSIA, WE ARE AGNOSTIC
ON BOTH, DON'T LIVE IN EITHER
COUNTRY, DON'T PLAN TO, DON'T
CARE TO.
IT'S NOT A MATTER OF PREFERRING
ONE OVER THE OTHER.
IF IT'S A STUBBORN INSISTENCE ON
DEFINING WORDS ACCURATELY
BECAUSE THEY MATTER IN THIS
COUNTRY.
IF YOU SUBVERT THE MEANING OF A
WORD AS FUNDAMENTAL AS
"DEMOCRACY," MAYBE YOU CAN
TAMPER WITH THE WAY WE LIVE HERE
IN THE UNITED STATES, JUST SPIT
FALLING FOR A SECOND.
SO UKRAINE, TO BE TECHNICAL, IS
NOT A DEMOCRACY.
DEMOCRACIES DON'T ARREST
POLITICAL OPPONENTS AND THEY
DON'T SHUTDOWN OPPOSITION MEDIA,
BOTH OF WHICH UKRAINE HAS DONE.
AND BY THE WAY, UKRAINE --
AGAIN, THAT'S FINE.
WE ARE NOT MAD ABOUT THAT, GO
AHEAD AND RUN UKRAINE IF YOU
THINK YOU CAN DO A BETTER JOB
THAN UKRAINE IS, JUST DON'T TELL
US IT'S DEMOCRACY.
BUT AS LONG AS THE CORE GOAL OF
AMERICAN FOREIGN POLICY IS TO
DEFEND DEMOCRACY AND OPPOSE
ANYONE WHO IS NOT RUNNING A
DEMOCRACY, YOU'VE GOT TO KIND OF
WONDER -- AND THIS MAY BE
OCCURRING TO THESE COUNTRIES --
WHAT ABOUT OUR FRIENDS IN
JORDAN, QATAR, SAUDI ARABIA?
WHAT ABOUT AT LEAST 50 COUNTRIES
IN AFRICA, NONE OF WHICH IS A
DEMOCRACY.
ARE THEY IN TROUBLE TOO?
ARE WE BE SENDING ADVANCED
WEAPONS SYSTEMS TO TOPPLE THOSE
NONDEMOCRACIES JUST ON
PRINCIPLES?
ARE THOSE THE VALUES WE ARE
DEFENDING AS WE LIVE THROUGH
HIGHER INFLATION AND HIGHER GAS
PRICES AND GET STEADILY POOR?
WOULD ALSO BE INTERESTING TO
KNOW IF THE PEOPLE YOU JUST SAW
TALKING ABOUT DEMOCRACY ARE AS
EXERCISED BY CHINA'S LACK OF
DEMOCRACY.
IF CHINA EVER MOVES AGAINST
TAIWAN, WILL WE GET THE SAME
LECTURES?
PROBABLY NOT.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY'S DONORS
HAVE GROWN RICH FROM THE CHINESE
NONDEMOCRACY.
IN OTHER WORDS, THE
DICTATORSHIP.
NANCY PELOSI'S FAMILY HAS GROWN
RICH FROM THAT DICTATORSHIP.
SO DON'T EXPECT TO HEAR
NANCY PELOSI COMPARE CHAIRMAN XI
TO HITLER ANYTIME SOON.
DEBATES ABOUT WHAT IS OR WHAT IS
NOT A DEMOCRACY ARE INTERESTING,
AND THEY MAY HAVE SOME ACADEMIC
IMPORTANCE.
BUT IN THE FACE OF THE MATERIAL
REALITY OF LIFE IN THE
UNITED STATES, FOR EXAMPLE HOW
MUCH DO THINGS COST, CAN I
AFFORD THEM, DOES THE PLANE LAND
ON TIME, DOESN'T LAND SAFELY,
CAN I TAKE THE SUBWAY OR MY
GOING TO GET STABBED BY MENTAL
PATIENT, SOMEBODY LET OUT ONTO
THE STREET?
THOSE OF THE REALITIES THAT
ACTUALLY MATTER, NOT JUST IN
THIS COUNTRY, BUT IN EVERY
COUNTRY.
IN THE VERY PEOPLE PUSHING THIS
DEFENSE OF DEMOCRACY ARE THE
VERY PEOPLE WHO HAVE MADE THOSE
MATERIAL REALITY IS MUCH WORSE
THIS COUNTRY.
AND UNTIL THEY ANSWER F